William J duiker who was Ho Chi Min Ho
Chi Minh of course to most Americans was
the leader of the Vietnamese
revolutionary movement a movement of
course that caused us enormous
difficulty for 15 20 years I think most
Americans see in that way I think to the
rest of the world he's also for many
people living in Asia Africa Latin
America he's a symbol of the national
liberation movement and of course within
the what used to be known as the
Communist world he was one of the
international figures of that movement
along with Stalin and Mao Zedong was he
an iceless or communist or bah he was
both he started out certainly with
strong patriotic leanings but in the
course of his early maturity became
convinced that capitalism was a system
that was very oppressive to not only two
peoples like the Vietnamese but to the
working class around the world and he
became well in France he became a
convinced Marxist and stayed that to the
end of his days what year did he die
1969 how old was he 79 years old and
what did he die of I think he died
probably like many people of a
combination of things but basically
basically a form of congestive heart
failure
when we were there in 92 we had some
video shot of the mausoleum and I want
you to talk through why this kind of a
mausoleum have you been there yes I have
he'll be on the screen just a second and
what's the origin of this in fact the
the origin of it has to go back to Ho
Chi Minh's testament which he drafted
over a period of years in the last few
years of his life and he indicated in
his Testament that he wanted to be
cremated and he wanted to have his ashes
distributed both North Center and south
so that the people of all Vietnam would
have a chance to venerate him but after
his death the Vietnamese leadership
decided that they needed some physical
symbol and they undertook a fairly
comprehensive study of the kind of
symbol they wanted they looked at
Lenin's Mazel
they looked at the Lincoln Memorial and
a number of other memorial buildings
around the world and they settled on
this one which I would have say many
people including myself feel is
singularly inappropriate for his memory
because it's very heavy and Lenin esque
it's very moving I would say when you go
through it did you go through the it
yeah and you see his his remains there
but it doesn't seem to fit his
personality and I think a lot of people
have been a little disappointed are
those his remains there yes mm-hmm
the area was it called Baden my squared
n square correct supposedly and when we
taped this you never know how it's going
to come out by the time it airs but that
area is supposedly been blocked off for
cleanup
during the time that President Clinton
is there for this visit mm-hmm coming up
this week and what's that all about do
you think I wonder if the cleanup is
meant as a more or less a kind of a
political statement or you think it's
just generally well I wonder what you
know that the reports when it first came
out were they didn't want the president
going there to pay homage to Ho Chi Minh
what would it a man if he did you mean
to the Vietnamese or dust or to us yeah
I would obviously be a controversial
statement there are many Americans and
certainly many Vietnamese immigrants
living in the United States you see Ho
Chi Minh is a symbol of oppression and
brutality and I think if he does go
there and it's a it's televised and
shown back in the United States it will
arouse a good deal of debate from his
standpoint I certainly couldn't try to
anticipate how he feels about it he may
feel this is sort of symbolic statement
embracing the idea of reconciliation of
the two people's what are the Vietnamese
people think of me it can be a divisive
issue but my experience in traveling
there on many occasions is that the
certainly the vast majority of people
living in the North still venerate him
his reputation is a lot more
controversial in the south where some
people feel that he's a representative
of a repressive system interestingly
enough
for many young Vietnamese he has no more
particularly nning than say Abraham
Lincoln to the average American he's
some old guy you know that they look
back on and say this is one of the
founders of our country but many
Vietnamese I talked to who are of course
much too young to remember the war will
say we don't really remember the war
we're ready to get on with our lives
you've got some photos in your book and
there's the first one we want to show is
it looks like it's odd I don't know
you'll see in just a moment it's the one
where he is very young and it's on the
screen here now you can see it over
there on that monitor if you look one
with the top hat yeah yes I some of
these pictures are hard to to locate
precisely because there are pictures
that were in the French archives and
they're not really identified but in the
course of analyzing some of his
activities in Paris this was a picture
that I believe was taken by the French
security services simply to be able to
identify them and as you can see there
he's very dapper and top hat and so
forth and it's an interesting picture in
some ways because it's so out of
character for the image that he
projected in the last years of his life
the simple Uncle Ho who wore a kind of a
bush jacket and that sort of thing why
did he go to Paris he went to Paris
originally in the years before World War
one probably to contact some friends of
his father's who were engaged in the
what we might call the Vietnamese
independence movement and he was already
at that time very much dedicated to
doing whatever he could deliberate his
country and I think he hoped to link up
with these people and perhaps get and
get involved in the national liberation
struggle
later on he left France before the war
and then came back at the end of World
War one and immediately came to the
attention of the entire nation of France
because he submitted the famous petition
to the victorious Allies meeting in
Versailles at the Versailles peace
conference in which he and a
demanded that Woodrow Wilson live up to
the promise of the fourteen points
involving self-determination of people's
and that brought him to the attention of
the entire country and of course word
eventually seep back to Vietnam there's
a picture in here when he was arrived in
the Soviet Union in 1923 what are the
circumstances for this picture mm-hmm
it's you can't see it's over there on I
see it yes that was probably taken in
the Soviet Union but there again it's
not quite clear exactly one of course
very clean shaven at that time two of
the things that show up there that are
interesting actually three one I think
you can tell in this picture how
singular are his eyes it's the one thing
that so many of his acquaintances would
say back in those days that he was a
very unprepossessing young man very
unassuming modest and demeanor and
demeanor of course he didn't dress in a
and certainly in any imposing way but
the eyes were the type of eyes that
would penetrate into your soul a second
thing I notice here is that he's wearing
a tie and he claimed in his later years
that he'd never worn a necktie in his
life so this is one of the many
instances where he he in effect used his
images that kindly old Uncle Ho to sort
of make a point which of course his life
will often show is not the case the
Third Point interestingly there is the
shape of his ear the French security
services for many many years we're
trying to identify Ho Chi Minh and
because he was living and working under
an assumed name when he joined the
French Communist Party and they were
very concerned to find out where he came
from and what his background was and
they they suspected that he was a young
man who had been evicted from high
school back in 1980s was before his
foreign travels who had gotten involved
in an anti French demonstration and
they'd evicted him from school and he
disappeared from view and then
eventually went to France and what they
determined was that the information
they'd had on him that he had a certain
type of deformity in his ear and they
from pictures like this they were able
to say indeed that's the same young man
he would have been about 34 in 1924
that's correct
there's some debate over when he was
born but based on what I've been able to
determine on his movements he was
probably born in 1890 so he would have
been about 34 at that time how big was
Vietnam in the 1890 to 1920 era
physically you mean physically and
population mm-hmm the total population
perhaps at that time may have been about
15 14 15 million in terms of the size of
the country at that time it wasn't even
a country it was divided up into three
separate sections by the French two
sections were technically under the
authority of the Vietnamese imperial
court although under French protection
and the southern part of the country was
actually a French colony so there
literally was no Vietnam at that time
how did the French get control how did
they manage to take it over it was part
of the was part of that thrust outward
of European capitalist countries in the
19th century when they were looking for
cheap raw materials and markets and the
French had been involved in Indochina
for 200 years primarily a Christian
missionary work so when the British
began to penetrate into Burma to the
west and of course there was a great
interest in the China market at that
time the French felt in a competitive
manner that they needed to build their
own colony in the area and they looked
upon Vietnam and neighboring Laos and in
Cambodia is their best opportunity we
have another picture from 1924 after
leaving Moscow for South China mmm-hmm
well what were the circumstances that
day looks a lot different here than he
did that other picture he does doesn't
he looks very serious and somber and all
it looks like a different hairdo he had
gone to to Moscow in 1923 at the
invitation of the Soviet leadership and
they they wanted him to perform in
Moscow basically as a kind of token
Asian they're not treating him entirely
seriously but just having him there is a
kind of symbol of the fact that the
International communist move
had its objective to help liberate the
colonial people's and he stayed there in
training and working at the communist
international headquarters for a while
and then he became very impatient and he
said I need to go back and help organize
my people and build a Communist Party in
in Indochina as the French called their
territory there and he had to he
literally had to plead for permission to
go back not to Vietnam where he would
have of course been at that time he
would have been under arrest so he went
back to South China and created the
first revolutionary movement out of the
emigres community living there so that's
one of the pictures that was probably
taken around that time how often was he
married interesting question it's not
certain that he was ever married in the
Western sense in other words that what
we think of course is the wedding
ceremony there's adequate evidence that
he had serious liaisons on a number of
occasions and that he had at least a
Chinese marriage to a young Chinese
woman while he was in Guangzhou
Cantona's we used to know it and he
established a relationship with a young
woman there and lived with her for about
two years and then when he was forced to
leave the area after John kai-shek began
to crack down on the Communists he and
his then Chinese wife lost track of each
other who is this lady in this picture
that is a young man a young woman we
know is wind team in KY who's probably
the most famous female revolutionary in
Vietnam she was a young woman who joined
the party in the very late let's say
around 1930 and was sent to Hong Kong
because he had his headquarters there
very briefly just at the time the
Communist Party was first created and
based on internal documentary evidence
letters that were written to Moscow and
that sort of thing
it appears that the two developed a a I
say sexual relationship certainly an
intimate relationship and there are
scattered letters that indicate that at
that time he actually requested
permission from Moscow to get married
he didn't formally identify who the wife
was but it's quite clear that this is a
young woman and either they were
formerly married or at least that they
were at the point where they were about
to be married and then both of them were
arrested and were separated for several
years the irony of all of this is that
when they next meet each other again it
was in Moscow at a major meeting of
international communist parties and at
that time she is listed as coming to
Moscow as his wife and yet after she
arrives there she becomes engaged to and
marries one of Ho Chi Minh's chief
lieutenants what happened to her
eventually she went back to Vietnam with
her new husband who was also of course
the leading figure in the movement they
were both arrested in the late 1930s and
both were executed so she died in 1940
and it's it's frankly one of the great
mysteries of the life of Ho Chi Minh is
a puzzle in other words what was the
relationship and how did how did the
relationship come to an end why did you
think that a book on Ho Chi Minh would
sell I'm not sure you think of it that
way but what were here and and why did
the hyperion people think he would say I
can go I guess in two or three different
directions on this I first became
interested in the book before the end of
the war and I think at that time and so
far as they thought of it in marketable
terms I thought Ho Chi Minh would be a
fascinating subject because he was the
public image of our adversary I found
out after the war was over that for many
years Americans lost interest in Vietnam
obviously was a humiliation for us and
there really wasn't much of a market for
the subject and I dropped it for that
reason and some others and then it came
back to it in the last decade or so
because more and more information was
coming out about him particularly from
Russia and from China and from Vietnam
itself and I have to say honestly I
wrote it out of a strong impulse in
myself that I wanted to understand this
man and the fact that it came out as a
book is almost
secondary and I was delighted that
Hyperion was interested in it I I think
based on my conversations with the
people there that that I think they hope
that it will sell but I think they felt
also that it was a topic that needed
discussing and I think most of my
friends in the Viet Nam field would
agree we need we really need to
understand how Chi Minh to understand
the Vietnam War you write that the air
of mystery around this man still remains
intact after of all the research and the
stuff that you've written well any
author I guess would like to feel that
he's answered every question and I do
feel that I've I've certainly penetrated
some of the mysteries around his life I
think I've picked out his movements and
pinned them down I personally feel that
I have a fairly good idea of what made
him tick if you work with someone long
enough you know you feel like you've
penetrated into that person's skin and
and I feel I understand but I do see him
as a very complex individual he's a man
of enormous simplicity but enormous
complexity he's a man who was very
affable very friendly very unassuming he
was very easy to like almost everyone
who met him enjoyed him and and found
themselves drawn to his personality and
yet there was this fierce steely
determination inside him that was
driving this man and in those cases
where where he found you know where he
found it necessary either to utilize his
image or to eliminate his rivals he was
perfectly capable of doing that
so I think that's the that's the hard
thing to penetrate is just how these
various factors in his personality tied
in together and how he perhaps how he
saw himself say he was in prison in Hong
Kong and here's a picture of him right
after he was released from the Hong Kong
prison he was in prison there in the
summer of 1931 he was captured by the
British police as part of a general
roundup of communist operatives all over
East and Southeast Asia and they did not
have anything concrete against him
except the scattering of materials in
his office that that suggested that he
was engaged in revolutionary activity
the problem was for the authorities was
that his activities had nothing to do
with colony of Hong Kong they had to do
with Indochina so what they the British
had to do was decide whether to
extradite him and send him back to
Indochina for the French to try and
convict for treasonous activities and it
became a very serious debate within the
government in Hong Kong and in London
over whether that was the proper thing
to do and as it finally turned out
various groups in Great Britain were
able to persuade the government that he
should be released because there was
nothing concrete to charge him with and
he should be allowed to go to the
destination of his own choosing so he
was finally spirited out of Hong Kong on
a sampan out to awaiting Chinese
steamship and the steamship took him up
to coast and eventually dropped him off
and around Shanghai and the French from
that point on until World War Two
weren't sure where he was in fact
sometimes they thought he died in prison
how long did you work on this book off
and on probably for twenty-five years
but I mentioned before that I had taken
it up briefly at the end of the war and
at that time I realised there was not
sufficient material to write the kind of
biography I wanted so I dropped it and
finally got to the point about ten years
ago when I could see more and more
information coming out and I still had
that fascination with him to me it's
it's almost like a detective story it's
almost like writing an Agatha Christie
novel but you don't know the end of it
when you started what is new in here
that no one's ever gotten before of I
think perhaps it's more sort of the
overall picture I find as I go through
this that I'm confirming a lot of things
that I think certainly those of us who
were acquainted with him know I think
there are some things I've discovered
that add nuances to our to our knowledge
about him for example his very delicate
relationship with the Soviet Union and
the China and with the leaders of those
two countries Stalin and Khrushchev and
Mao Zedong Joe and I and that sort of
thing and I can flesh out that relation
ship and and it's a I think it's very
clear that he was a very central figure
in the International communist movement
he tried to resolve the sino-soviet
dispute I think I think I've clarified
the issue of his attitude toward
nationalism and revolution certainly to
my own feeling I've clarified the fact
that he was a genuine revolutionist he I
wouldn't say he was that interested in
Marxism but that he was very much a
believer in revolution and those people
who say he was just a patriot who was
driven to the Soviet Union by the fact
that America brushed him off is not
entirely active I accurate I think he
would have certainly tried to make a
relationship with the United States but
his commitment to to socialism and
perhaps even in a very general sense the
the concept of a communist utopia was
genuine how long did he spend in the
United States there's that's the gap
that's the hardest to fill because we
know primarily by his own statements
that he arrived in the United States
about 1912 or so while he was sailing on
a steam French steamship liner and he
left the ship either in Baltimore or New
York and he spent by his own account
several months in New York City living
in Manhattan and perhaps Harlem and
Queens Brooklyn maybe and then went up
to Boston and worked there very briefly
and then left at an unknown time and
went back to Europe and with the help of
some other people who were interested in
and we've tried to locate something in
the immigration records and there's
absolutely nothing he must have just
gotten off the ship you know sort of
disappeared into the throng of
immigrants living in the big cities in
the East Coast spent some time here
learned some English and then went back
to England and it's not England and
France and it's not entirely clear even
by his own account exactly why he did
this have you ever heard his voice I
have I have heard his voice on tape his
voice when he gave the famous
declaration of independence at body and
square
in September of 1945 what's it sound
like fairly high-pitched I'm tempted to
say squeaky but it may be the quality of
the tape it's a it's a very high sharp
voice it reminded me a little bit of the
voice of John kai-shek or even Mao
Zedong when they speak and as I said
that may have something to do with the
quality of a you know of radio
transcription and that sort of thing he
had a very strong central Vietnamese
accent what would have happened in your
opinion in the Vietnam country and also
the American war in Vietnam had Ho Chi
Minh not been there uh at a minimum it
wouldn't have been at all the same kind
of revolution and I would say it for
this for this way it was Ho Chi Minh who
who devised the idea that the best way
to approach the Vietnamese people and
appeal to their instincts was not talk
about communism and the classless utopia
and collective farms and that sort of
thing but to talk about two dramatic
forces which were shaping Vietnamese
Society in the 20th century and one
would be the issue of national
independence of course based on the
French conquest of Vietnam in the 19th
century and the other is a somewhat
broader populist appeal that I tend to
call social justice which means land to
the tiller it means decent working
conditions an opportunity for education
he knew at that time that you couldn't
appeal to the Vietnamese people 95% of
whom were farmers with communist slogans
you had to talk to them in the language
that they understood and there was no
one else in Vietnam at that time or I
think even among his colleagues later on
who could quite understand that gift
that he had secondly I think his
strategical instincts were very
important I think to a degree he
followed the what I think many people
know is the Maoist idea people's war
guerrilla struggle and that sort of
thing but he was very good
get in these context and he he
discovered very early on because he
already become a sophisticated observer
of the international scene that for
Vietnam to be liberated however he might
define that it could not be done for
example the way the Bolshevik Revolution
had taken place or even the Chinese
Civil War it couldn't be done entirely
on a domestic basis because Vietnam was
a small country controlled by a large
powerful European country he had to have
support on the international scene so he
very early learned to sort of tie the
liberation struggle in Indochina with
international events and with trying to
manipulate what we might call the great
Power Balance when was the first time
you went to Vietnam I was first in
Vietnam in 1964 1965 at that time I was
a foreign service officer and I was
stationed with US Embassy and Saigon and
it's where I first got interested in Ho
Chi Minh what did you do at the Embassy
I was an economic reporting officer I
had prior to my assignment there I had
been assigned to Chinese language
training in Taiwan and when I was
assigned to Saigon after my Chinese
language training was over I was a bit
puzzled then I discovered that in the
economic reporting office they always
wanted one Chinese speaker to deal with
the large overseas Chinese business
community in Saigon so in a light moment
I will sometimes say that I was sent to
Vietnam to win the support of the
Chinese community to the South
Vietnamese causes in the war in a
footnote in the back you say that one
weekend you went to Bangkok for the
weekend by the time you came back the
government that was in control when you
left was out the government that took
over was out and there was a third
government in charge well that's right
what's that story I don't know much
about it from that because I've never
followed it up at the time that during
that period from 1964 to 1965 there were
innumerable coos and some of them were
act
actually involve tanks going up into the
presidential palace lawn and other case
cases they were just you know
reshuffling of the cabinet and that sort
of thing and this was at a time when
there was a kind of token civilian
government in power in Saigon but the
military was sitting in the background
sort of moving the musical chairs around
and I'd gone off to Bangkok just for a
couple of days to see some friends and
over the weekend there was some
reshuffling of the cabinet in such a way
that it was almost like a coup d'etat in
other words it wasn't just an
appointment and then I guess I came back
on a Monday and by that time that
particular group had been replaced by
another group and that process which I
always described as a kind of musical
chairs game lasted for about a year and
a half until the the rise of wind kalki
and when van - about two months later
they came in power in June of 65 who was
the American ambassador when you were in
the embassy I arrived just after Maxwell
Taylor arrived
general Taylor was there for about a
year a little bit over a year and then
he left in the early summer mid summer
of 65 and Henry Cabot Lodge came back
for a second tour of duty so I was there
briefly when Henry Cabot Lodge had come
back for a second term buried in your
book is a reference to laid one who was
he now hey there's a lot of them but
there's one particular reference I want
to ask you ladies Juan was a young
Communist Party functionary from central
Vietnam who had emerged during his early
to mid 30s around the time of the Second
World War into a position of leadership
this was a time when there was enormous
shake-up in the party because the number
were captured and put to death and laid
one began to emerge during the Second
World War is a very effective party
member and after the war was over
because of his background in Central and
South Vietnamese affairs he was assigned
to the south to to command the party's
political and military activities in
South Vietnam
he essentially stayed in the south right
up through the mid-1950s in other words
at a time when the United States had
come in to support the new government in
South Vietnam and in nineteen 1956 or
early 1957 he was ordered north to Hanoi
where the government had established its
a power base after the Geneva Conference
and became active acting general
secretary which meant he was primarily
the most powerful person in the and the
end the Communist Party and the general
feeling is and I certainly share it that
he was given that position primarily
because of his enormous commitment to
unification and liberation of the south
and it was more or less a symbolic
statement that unification is going to
be one of our top priorities for the
next few years the reason I bring him up
is that you know there are a number of
issues that we still can get a good
argument started about me and I says one
of them is did the Vietnamese attack our
destroyers there in the Tonkin Gulf or
vice versa and who did what to whom you
say that laid want old Mao I believe
that it was a local decision to attack
which I don't know was its eternal joy
one of those yes the Maddox and I got
excited Roy Wright is that new I don't
believe so I think some other scholars
have there are one or two major studies
on the whole Tonkin Gulf incident and of
course the consequences of it and I
think that's I think that's something
that is becoming clear some of the
conversations that I report between the
Vietnamese and the Chinese may be fairly
new although these are this is
information available to other people as
well do you agree with that there was a
local decision yes I think by my reading
it was a local decision based on perhaps
on the assumption that the US actions
there the the two American warships were
related to some South Vietnamese
guerrilla operations taking place in the
vicinity and the local authorities then
reported it to the north and if I recall
I'm not too precise on my knowledge on
us that the northerners approved it
the North Vietnamese insist and I think
correctly that they had not that there
had been no second attack that that may
have been just electronic emissions or
something where did you go for the new
information the Ho Chi Minh I would say
the bulk of my information came from
Vietnam I was able to go back to Hanoi
on several occasions to engage in
research I had a little access to the
archives I talked to a number of
scholars I was able to interview some
people who had known Ho Chi Minh and I
think a lot of the information came from
there I was able to find a good deal of
information in the last few years from
memoirs and collections of documents
that have been published in China the
Chinese are they don't open their
archives to foreigners as a general rule
certainly not in a matter of sensitive
as sino-vietnamese relations but they
have taken to publishing the
reminiscences of some of their
ambassadors and some of their military
commanders and a lot of that is very
useful the Russian archives have been
open just peek and now it's possible to
see some of that information and then
finally certainly an enormous amount of
information came from the French
archives they during the colonial period
they kept a very close watch on Ho Chi
Minh when did their French get kicked
out of Indochina out of Vietnam in 1954
at the close of the Geneva Conference
which divided Vietnam temporarily in two
separate zones with the yet men as they
recall then the communist party in
control in the north and pro-french or
at least anti-communist Vietnamese
settling in the south and the United
States immediately decided to back the
South Vietnamese government to stop the
further spread of communism if you don't
mind
from 1890 until 1969 block out Ho Chi
Minh's life I know thirty years he spent
outside of Vietnam where were the major
points nineteen eight I think when he
engaged in that anti French
demonstration in the imperial capital of
way that's what that was his first open
pledge
galactic it it basically you might say
it started him on a revolutionary career
18 years old that he was about 17 or 18
at the time
three years later he sailed from Saigon
to Europe I say Europe because he
stopped in France but he went elsewhere
as well spent
three or four years working on an ocean
liner or as I said settling briefly in
in the United States most of World War
one he was apparently in Great Britain
although it's hard to pin down his
activities 1917 1918 he arrived in Paris
and that's where he joined the Socialist
Movement and a founding member of the
Communist Party 1923 ordered to Moscow
for training late 1924 on to China I
have a joke with my wife that we really
ought to we should have put a pedometer
on him so that we should have kept track
of his activities because he must have
been the most peripatetic man you can
see lake 24 to china 1927 he was evicted
or forced to leave China because of
Zhang kai-shek's crackdown on communists
he went back to Moscow and travelled in
Europe
the late 20s he went back to Southeast
Asia lived in Thailand for a few months
went to Hong Kong to found the Communist
Party arrested two years in prison in
Hong Kong after release he went back to
the Soviet Union where he spent five
years do I go on sure I came back and
when I get to the point where he's in
charge right in nineteen in nineteen
nineteen thirty-eight he was permitted
to go back to China to re-establish
contact with his party and finally was
able to do so in nineteen sometime in
the spring of 1940 and that from that
point on literally until his final days
he was in direct contact with his close
followers and and if not the leader of
the Communist Party certainly its most
influential public figure and from 41 to
45 he was
early in neither in South China or
northern Vietnam organizing his
revolutionary movement the fall of or
late summer of 1945 when the war was
over he and a ragtag group of 5,000
troops marched in Hanoi raised the flag
of the new Democratic Republic of
Vietnam that's where he made his famous
speech and body ins and square for the
next 18 months he was engaged in
negotiations with a French in order to
gain some form of autonomy or
independence trying to appeal to the
United States for some measure of
recognition or legitimacy those
negotiations broke down in late 46 and
from December 46 until 1954 he was back
in the bush leading his movement against
the French after Geneva his party came
back to Hanoi and he spent his last or
the last 15 years of his life as
president of the country where is this
photograph from he's there with this
that that was a photograph taken in late
1945 perhaps early 1946 when he had been
named a president of a Democratic
Republic of Vietnam and that's a more
formal photo photograph of him obviously
a fairly posed one I have here instant
in your book the document that you
reprinted it says via the War Department
Ho Chi Minh president provincial
government of Vietnam transmitted our
harry s truman mm-hmm and it reads mr.
president on behalf of vietnam people
and government i wish to express to you
our sincere gratitude for the
decorations in twelve points you've made
on the US foreign policy that decoration
is enthusiastically welcomed by our
people as the opening of a new era for
the apposed nations all over the world
what's this and why is it important it
is one of it is one of several
communications that he sent either to
President Roosevelt or President Truman
or
one of our secretaries of state it was
part of a long process that began in
late 1944 early 1945 when he he he
realized at the end of the war that this
was a marvelous opportunity to liberate
his country because Japanese surrender
would create a vacuum in Indochina and
the French had been French authorities
had been in prison by the Japanese so
there would be this short window when
the job when the yet men might be able
to seize control but he recognized that
for that for that process to succeed he
needed to gain international recognition
of his new government and he was well
aware of the fact Soviet Union had
relatively little interest Stalin never
did care much about Indochina and what
he deduced from the situation was that
given the circumstances at the end of
the war with the United States allied
with the Soviet Union and Great Britain
and the grand alliance and with of
course Roosevelt's reputation as being
anti French in an anti-colonialist he
hoped somehow that he would be able to
induce the United States to support the
legitimacy of his government rather than
support a return of the French and this
is one of the later messages that he set
off to Washington in the hope that
somehow the Americans would see some
benefit in supporting his movement when
was he no longer involved really
involved in the decisions it generally
in in the political scene it's probably
hard to be overly specific because in
his last few years he he suffered from a
number of physical ailments and also I
think I couldn't give any kind of a
medical diagnosis on it but from people
I've known who saw him in operation at
that time occasionally mentally he would
sort of drift out of the picture they
would see him for example in important
international conferences and he'd be
sort of staring off into space and that
process was sort of an ongoing process
I had interviews with the Vietnamese in
particular who insists that up to about
1964 90
sixty-five he was very active in helping
to direct the Vietnamese political
activities but from 1965 on apparently
he went downhill quite rapidly
and I think one of the one of the one of
the things I'm able to bring out in this
book fairly clearly is the degree to
which he began to lose control or
influence over his movement not only
after 1965 but to a certain degree
beginning in the early to mid 1950s
there's a story in here that he wanted
to go south during the American War I
believe from the north to the south
surreptitiously mm-hmm but didn't get to
why and what's that story it's a very
moving story this would have been about
1967 1968 when this was around the time
of the Tet Offensive and he had he had
been in Beijing for medical treatment he
was quite weak at the time and as I said
I think perhaps some of his mental
acuity had begun to drain away at this
point and he always wanted to visit the
south and he felt very strongly about
his symbolic importance to the people in
the south and the fact that they had
struggled so long for their own
liberation and I think he was very
sensitive to the fact that many
southerners complained that he had sold
them out at the Geneva Conference
because he'd allow the division of the
country and he wanted to go south
obviously to travel through NLF held
areas and raised the spirits of the
people but his physical condition my
sense is simply didn't permit it so that
he was being very unrealistic at this
time so that what his colleagues had to
do many of many reviewers of course will
remember Ladak toes Henry Kissinger's
opposite number during the Paris treaty
he went to Beijing I think after the Tet
Offensive to report the Ho Chi Minh Anh
what had happened at at and tell Ho Chi
Minh that negotiations were beginning
hope who hadn't been involved in these
and it may have been about that time
when ho said I want to go south now
because things are looking better and
later tow more or less pom damoff and
said we can't take you there
you'd be recognized and you might be you
know and you might be arrested and and
Tochi men said well maybe you could take
me secretly by sea down around to
southern Cambodia and sneak me in that
way but he also said he won that he can
he be willing to shave his beard he be
willing to shave his beard so he
wouldn't be recognized it's a really
it's quite a moving story and if you if
you if you become in a sense sort of
attached to Ho Chi Minh as an individual
whatever you know whatever one thinks of
his is a political ideology it's it's
almost pathetic to see this man
desperately wanting you know to get uh
sort of hands-on relationship with the
people on the south but you also said
that then I may be late Actos said this
but if you shave off your beard the
people in the South are gonna who you
are that's right where did that story
come from um it came from it came from
two or three different reminiscences
have been published in the last few
years
reminiscences by Vietnamese and I think
to a certain degree may be comments made
by later Tom self but not I might say
for for broad public dissemination in
Vietnam because it you know it obviously
undercuts the image of Uncle Ho is
firmly in charge of the country right to
is the end of his days how many times
have you been to Hanoi uh probably
somewhere between five and ten times
first trip 1985 for a research visit
last year nice trip last trip last trip
the must have been about 1996 or 97 if I
count right this is your 14th book
somewhere in that range I I'm always a
little imprecise about it not not by any
means trying to say I've written so many
I don't even think about it but some of
the things that that I might think of as
a book are relatively short and they
might be considered you know research
papers or something of that type so it's
somewhere around that 700 pages $35
it's a lot of pages big book a lot of
dollars yeah are you worried that it's
too big if the if my editor isn't
worried about it I guess I'm not worried
about where's the picture from that's a
picture that was taken about nineteen
early nineteen or mid nineteen fifty
four just at the end of what we call the
Franco Viet Minh war when the French
were fighting against the revolutionary
forces and from what I've gathered from
the context this was a moment of general
repose when the war was just about one
and he's in his again his bush jacket
waiting to go back to Hanoi how many
names did he have in his life somewhere
between 50 and 100 and indeed there are
undoubtedly more that we don't know
about what was he born name his name his
first name was what the Vietnamese call
a milk name which is just the name the
infant is given to begin with and his
name was Winston Cohen at age 11 or 12
it's at that point where adolescence
begins and then the parents will give a
young man or a young woman a name
representing their aspirations for their
child and at that point he was called
win tun which means a win which is one
of the familiar family names in Vietnam
tucked on meaning he who will succeed or
he who will become he kept that name
until he left Vietnam and it was when he
left Vietnam that he began using various
aliases where do you come down in the
Vietnam War give a position after all
this I have a position but it's a it's
somewhat of a conflicted one and I've
always been very honest about it it may
have to do in part with my age in my
background I grew up at a time when
Americans still believe very strongly in
the correctness of our foreign policy
objectives I believed in us containment
policy I believe that it was necessary
although I I might say I thought I'd
been much to militarize
I went into the State Department almost
literally at the time John Kennedy
entered the White House and felt many of
the same feelings of enthusiasm that
that generation felt so when I was sent
to Vietnam when I was in the Foreign
Service I sort of carried as a badge of
honor the idea that I was doing a noble
service and then by the time I by the
time I got to Vietnam I for whatever
reason I was already quite skeptical
that we could win I had no particular
pleasure in seeing America lose I
certainly didn't glorify the
revolutionary movement in any particular
way I had no particular liking for
communism but I just thought it was a
mistake I thought we were in effect
throwing money into a lost situation
it's almost like a military campaign if
you're very exposed in a military
campaign you don't throw all of your
your troops into that point you back up
and you establish a you establish a more
defensible security perimeter and I just
felt based on my experience there and
perhaps my study of Chinese history
because there were some similarities
there I just felt that we were unlikely
to be successful in Vietnam and from
that point on I in whatever way I could
I was hoping that we would find some way
of extricate ourselves from Vietnam with
honor and as much as possible a minimum
of bloodshed for the Vietnamese people
when did you leave the Foreign Service
after the Vietnam assignment in the fall
of 1965 how old were you then
33 and where did you go next I my
doctoral studies at Georgetown
University I had started them before I
went overseas and after I finished my
doctorate on my name out for a job and
was accepted for a position in the
history department at Penn State how
long did you spend at Penn State 30
years full for career what are you done
now I retired a couple of years ago and
just cited last year to move down to the
Outer Banks the hurricane alley as we
call it in North Carolina and Lovett
down there where were you from
originally I bounced around a lot I was
born in Chicago spent many years in
Washington DC every time I come to
Washington I see a house I lived in or a
friend's house spent some time during my
adolescence in Philadelphia lived in
Miami Indiana went to school at
Dickinson College in Carlisle
Pennsylvania there's a series of
pictures in the book of where he lived
and I wanted to ask you which one you
think represents the Ho Chi Minh that
you've come to know in this book is it
the one here on top which is the palace
right near Baden square correct or is it
this near Budden square the stilt house
and how much times he's right next door
to the presidential palace and how much
time did he spend in both places the
presidential palace on top was a very
impressive late 19th century building
built by the French to represent the
grandeur of the French colonial empire
he moved there very very briefly after
the war I think that is 1945 1946 for
symbolic reasons it was very important
for the Vietnamese that they control the
presidential palace rather than the
French during that period after 1945
when they were negotiating with each
other but from the start he was very
uncomfortable with living there because
it was much too ostentatious so he did
not live there personally during that
particular period he lived in an
administrative office over toward the
center of town then when the the
the Viet Minh movement that is the party
leaders came back to Hanoi in October of
1954 he refused to occupy that residence
and he moved into the gardeners quarters
on the grounds of the presidential
palace and this would have been the mid
to late 50s that's correct that's the
fish pond that he often was seen sitting
there feeding the fish right beside it
and it was while he was living in the
gardeners quarters that the party
arranged to have this house built in the
style of the mountain minorities and he
lived there for most of the remainder of
his life during the during the bombing
campaign 65 to 68 and he often lived in
a bomb shelter also adjacent to these
quarters almost everything that's been
written about your book is positive
except one thing and I don't know if
you've seen this review have you seen
this in the amazon.com profile the one
from the Vietnamese yeah yes ban fom and
I just wanted to ask you about this
because he goes in these yeah it's it's
a little stilted English because he
obviously knows English pretty well but
it's but he he says I was eagerly
awaiting this book believing that it
contains information from the Russian
French and Vietnamese archives I was
thoroughly disappointed mm-hmm
what bottom this me about this book was
not so much the information the author
convey but the information that he
either through a coincident or on
purpose deliberately hide from his
reader mm-hmm
do you want to just take that you know
it was this guy on track it at all
I think in fairness to him I probably
would like to talk with him and see
whether he has information that wasn't
available to me because there's an
enormous amount of information and
misinformation about Ho Chi Minh out
around the world and certainly in the
internet and what I have tried to do is
to corroborate everything that I have
seen certainly anything that's
controversial so that I didn't find
myself simply repeating stories that for
which there wasn't any proper evidence
or maybe it was something put out as a
false
and I I think what public puzzled me a
little bit about that about that letter
was that one of the things he quoted is
the case of a young woman who apparently
became ho chi minh's concubine toward
the end of his life and there was a very
messy story about the fact that she was
raped by Ho Chi Minh's Minister of the
Interior and later her body was found in
the suburbs of Hanoi with the assumption
that she had been assassinated
perhaps because she'd given birth to Ho
Chi Minh's child and wanted and wanted
to marry him and of course this would
have been unacceptable given the image
of Ho is the celibate the fact is I do
report that story I don't dwell on it
unnecessarily because it's a little hard
to corroborate and I I don't want to
accentuate things where there may be
more that I don't know about but I do
report it and I certainly I I gather
from the kind of things that he's saying
that I downplay the degree of cruelty
and the degree of bloodshed that
occurred in Vietnam maybe the difference
there is that I don't I don't deny the
brutality and the bloodshed that took
place as I see it somewhat on both sides
but I certainly can see the Leninist
character of his government and I can
see is I think I mentioned to you before
that there are times when he was quite
willing to commit actions or order
actions that could involve very high
degree of casualties among his
supporters as well as among his enemies
and there were times when some of his
colleagues committed what to me are
quite brutal acts and the suppression of
their enemies and I find myself very
aware of that in some cases Ho Chi Minh
appeared to lack the political courage
to stop it you point out in your book
that ho Chi Minh wrote two
autobiographies under an assumed name
yes about himself and this upset this
reviewer who he quotes in here he says
many that this is tran dan 10 who is an
alias of Ho Chi Minh saying this is what
he wrote many Viet and foreign writers
and journalists have tried to write
biographies of the president of the
Democratic Republic of Vietnam
he's talking about himself but so far
they have not had little success they
have had a little success the reason is
simple again he's writing about himself
the modest president ho doesn't like to
be talked about too much later on the
book when the question of biography is
mentioned Howe replies biography that is
that is a good thing but at present our
people still live in poverty after 80
years of slavery our country is in ruin
and we have a big task of reconstruction
let's do what is most urgent first as
from my biography it can wait a quote
within a quote within an article that
I'm having trouble following yeah but in
other words Ho Chi Minh wrote these
phony biographies or autobiographies
under an assumed name writing about
himself in the book that he wasn't
interested in biography what did he take
on what's your take on that well I think
that's part of Ho Chi Minh image making
he certainly began to see himself at
some point as a symbol of his cause and
I think he realized his talent and in in
effect making himself the public image
of the movement and he saw in fact that
it was the appeal to his personality and
his character that was a large part of
the success of his movement do you read
Vietnamese I read it reasonably well I
do keep a dictionary handy and this book
Ho Chi Minh a life has there ever been a
book written like this not one of this
length and not one that I think delves
as much as as I have into his movements
there may be some people who say you're
talking along awful lot about where he
went and when and I do that in part
because that's been part of the mystery
of Ho Chi Minh is that he's seen
everywhere and it's important I think to
tie down his you know hit where he went
and why he did what he did and I've
tried to let the story speak for itself
here's the book it's called Ho Chi Minh
by William J duiker we thank you very
much for joining us thank you Brian